so here's one last helpful loop the for
in loop for in loops let us easily
iterate through arrays or objects the
syntax looks like this the same keyword
for we have some kind of iterator which
we can give any name that we want then
we have the keyword in and then an
object or array that we want to iterate
through for each of the items in some
object we want to do something just like
before we put the conditions for a for
loop inside parentheses and the
statements we want to execute inside
curly braces it's important to note here
that this item this iterator in this
list is actually the index of the item
in the object not the value held at the
index in the object so let's take a look
at an example we have an array called
countries which has the top four teams
of the 2014 World Cup we have a four in
loop here which is going to iterate for
each country in the countries array we
want to log that country hey James do
you see anything wrong with this code
it's just gonna print out 0 through 3
and not the actual country name why is
that because country is an iterator in
countries it's not the actual value of
country that's right so let's make a
change instead we should have
console.log countries of the index
country let's see if this is correct so
here's our foreign loop in one line of
code by using shift enter we can
actually put this in a much nicer format
so we see for country and countries
console.log countries country m and
pressing enter we see Germany Argentina
Brazil and the Netherlands you should
already have a work object with all of
your work experiences I want you to
write a 4 in loop that iterates over all
the jobs in your work object and appends
them in a new HTML work start element I
want you to also format each jobs
employer with HTML work employer in each
job title with HTML work title and
append all of that to the page click
this box when you're done